have you ever had any bad injuries or
have you ever had
any bad crashes or anything like that
are you not knock knock on wood no
you shouldn't ask someone you shouldn't
ask the person to drive cars that sort
of question
oh god what an [ __ ] uh yeah a lot of
i mean a lot of
small crashes but i mean that comes with
it but yeah i've seen
personally i've seen um there actually
there has been some big very severe
injuries at msu circuit from
i mean i can i can only write yeah right
yeah yeah it's a motorsport you yeah it
can be quite sketchy
i mean it used to be it used to be a lot
better because the speeds were lower and
people weren't quite as extreme now but
now everyone wants everyone's just going
flat out the whole time
yeah yeah yeah that's terrifying cars
rolling over and
okay here's the question i want to ask
though as someone who like is into the
drift scene obviously
initial d legit or no okay
uh because i've always wanted to know
like
you know because initial d is like kind
of put on this pedestal of like yes this
is the
drift anime yeah and even though there's
other ones like one gun midnight and
like all these other great ones
it's always like initial days like the
cream of the crop right yeah so i want
to know like as someone who's into that
scene
and who's probably watched a lot of
initial days i've seen all of it yeah
legit or not legit okay it's it's
that is like sort of saying like okay
you've if that's like saying saying
someone who is like
into computers saying is hackers like is
that
or like um you know someone who's into
surfing like oh it's point break like is
that what it's actually like right
it's it's like yes it's based a lot on
reality
obviously there's a lot of dramatization
yeah but honestly
initial d is pretty good
as far as sort of stuff is concerned now
so going all the way back to the start
uh the got the mangaka
uh shigenosuichi who wrote that
he his specialty is sort of like you
know teenage
romantic drama
and motorsport sort of thing
combination yeah i don't guess it's like
sort of a 1990s japan
um he's done other ones like um buddy
buddy densetsu which is based around
motorcycle racing
that was also an anime as well um there
was another one i
think it's like some something something
blue sky i forgot the name of it which
was like the precursor to initial d
where like the main character drove an
a86 you know and um
that's the main car international yeah
that's that's the main case and it was
set at like some sort of
rich kids summer like tennis camp or
something like that i don't know
right drifting around the tennessee well
there
anyway so then then came out initial d
so
yes that's it's mostly true because back
then
in the late 80s early 90s uh if you went
up to the mountains in
you know gunma saitama uh
anywhere around tokyo you'd find dudes
in like these little
cheap ripple drive corollas or sylvias
or things like that yeah
just just having just you know having
fun sliding around
uh having you know enjoying uh you know
saturday night yeah
and at the same time too yes there were
races
done up there i've spoken to this is one
of those things where the reality
is almost better than the fiction right
oh okay i've spoken to people i've
actually met
the real like the takumi fujiwara like
the real guy the guy who inspired
yeah yeah yeah there's a guy um he he
worked at a
uh at a tofu shop and he would deliver
the tofu up to the
the top of the mountain or some stuff
it's all based on reality yeah
um so cool like there's one guy i've i
know i've done a i did a job with him
once where he's uh a gymkhana champion
of japan
jim carter is where you uh it's like
like what you did with the cones
yeah yeah you've got to drive around as
fast as possible like an obstacle course
yeah you've got to remember it too it's
like you're going to go forward then
backwards here and around this three
times
it's very complicated it was a bit more
complicated than what we did
and so he's like one of the japanese
champions and i was talking
about yeah we used to go out to this
certain mountain i had a crx out there
and i was i was the fastest guy on the
mountain then one day
these guys showed up with a bunch of
civics and they were faster than me and
i was like oh i need to beat these guys
we had races and it's like
this sounds exactly like an initial
thing
yeah yeah it's the same thing and like
all the stuff you've seen initially like
for example there's a scene in that
where um a bunch of gangsters come up
the mountain
to like one of the one of the other
street racers calls like a bunch of gang
members
to come up to fight of course one of the
types of presidents
and then then they're all they'll see
the takashi and they're like oh senpai
like
that's real like guys would see this
thing about because it's street racing
it's not legal
right yeah so guys who are out to look
for fights would actually go up there
and like
try to start fights with street races
yeah so yeah all these little points you
see in the in that are like based on
some sort of reality
okay yeah that's that's pretty that's
right it's pretty good like
they talk about the like the different
kinds of cars that um you know their
strengths and weaknesses and like some
cars on certain uh toga and stuff like
that like like the one there's a the one
with the uh the spiral gtr which loses
its brakes going down a hill
right and the other two cars have to go
in front like stop it with this
like that's not i i know someone who had
to do that in real life
oh my god that's so cool i was watching
your videos and i saw there was just
like uh
an a a e a
yeah yeah that was so cool yeah so i i
i guess fortunately or unfortunately i
guess it's one of the things that made
me confident to reach out to you guys
was
some of my most popular videos on my
youtube channel are based around initial
d
yeah of course yeah and anime culture as
well yeah well
uh yeah it's uh it's i mean if you think
about it it's just a very expensive
cosplay
if you at that show there was the there
was the main characters
you know corolla there was the uh the
the takashi brothers rx7s
even the uh the new manga that's out now
uh uh what's it called ghost
uh mf ghost yeah maybe like the new
eight six with the number on the door
like there's
the people do cosplays of these like car
cosplays it's cosplay with attitude
that's what it is and i noticed that
even like the the japanese people like
knew you were like fans of you
oh yeah i mean because you're just like
because you go to these events so often
you kind of like i go to
these events also like a lot of my
videos that i know are going to be
popular with japanese people have
subtitles on them as well
there's not there's not a lot of uh car
content being
like car youtubers in japan i mean there
are yeah but um
i think people often say like i'm
because i'm looking at it from a
different
perspective yeah yeah like i'm like oh
look it's the initial d
car it's like because if a japanese
person does it's kind of cringey i guess
to them
yeah it's like yeah yeah yeah it's a
little weird how they are like that with
kind of anime yeah like stuff that is a
reference to an
anime and it's like oh yeah yeah this is
initial d thing
i get anyway whatever like dude it's
like be proud of it yeah
it's cool